speaking of old ass women j-lo and ben
affleck they're rekindling this [ __ ]
yeah and diddy's trying to hate
they're trying to get everybody trying
to get in there right you know what he's
trying to get his old thing back
i [ __ ] with that yeah that move that was
a fire move just throw back thursday go
back thursday
what did he do yeah yeah did he cause he
used to split that yeah
of course yeah he was the first yeah the
first of many he made her pop
whoa yep whoa you've seen money training
remember how bad she was in money trees
six train you gotta take it to the bronx
get yourself some chunklers
you gotta take turn up smoke yourself
some hookah
on the sixth string you wanna take it to
the bronx
get yourself a little north face that
comes up on you to your boy
and have a baby before you're 17 in the
sixth string
bronze isn't that
because she's from the bronx right yeah
i didn't know that about he got us
in the heights i thought she was from
the book crazy in the heights i've never
seen it
like jersey or something like that
montclair just from montclair
jenny from the block yeah
uh this i don't know what i am with
archives just the word block
knowing the chain could come back at it
it bothered me for that one moment that
i said the word yeah
no little boy he just hang tight bugs
him a little bit
it's gonna take a while we're gonna win
all right god bless i'm in i'm in
forever
you know me yeah uh okay but okay do we
have any feelings about it what do you
guys think you think
listen first of all this is what i
didn't like about it i remember ben
affleck made headlines like a few months
ago
when he was like oh i remember what the
headlines were saying about jlo
when we were dating and it was just so
sexist and misogynistic the horrible
things these reporters are saying
and i was like that seems odd from a
from a white guy from boston he wouldn't
give a [ __ ] about this
guy's worried about getting his dunkin
donuts inside and then i find out as
soon as they break up he'd been trying
to holler like don't use the media
he used wokeness to try to get [ __ ] and
i hate that yeah
anything i hate that cancel ben affleck
yo cancel this [ __ ]
he was on a dating app like three weeks
ago you remember this yeah yeah
i respect that though that's fire i like
that ben affleck yeah cheating on
everybody getting drunk
tattoos and [ __ ] yeah bro that's you you
saw the video where the girl unmatched
him yeah that was [ __ ] up what do you
think about that
well i mean she put it out right like
she's like she put him on blast
give the description away so basically
this girl's on do the thing that i tell
you never to do on stage
yeah i was talking about this this
weekend i was like yeah i could describe
it funny he goes no no more describing
the groundwork
so basically this girl's on tinder she
matches with ben affleck and she goes oh
there's obviously a fake account there's
no way i just matched with ben affleck
so she unmatched him and then he sent
her a video and goes
why'd you unmatch me it's me i'm i'm ben
affleck
and then she made a tick tock where she
was like lol remember that time i
matched with ben affleck
nobody remembers [ __ ] it happened to
just you on youtube i hate when they do
remember when
[ __ ] that's so annoying i hate it
remember when lebron you know
gave me his shirt after the game we
don't remember nobody knows anything
about your life that's the point of
the that's olivia rodrigo music that's
olivia ross
olivia rodrigo music okay mark so so go
on so then basically she puts out the
video puts him on blast and is like yo i
mashed with ben affleck like he was mad
thirsty
and she looks stupid and he looks all
right hmm
i think you look bad ain't nothing wrong
with being thirsty bruh why did you
unmatch me
it's me that's great but yo regular
[ __ ] look way better than hollywood
ones
i'm telling you all these actresses yeah
but you could be thirsty over j-lo don't
be thirsty over some chicken or upper
east side
you don't know what that girl looks like
roommates that girl probably hadn't been
engaged 12 times
like you we we all know that girl like
yo
see that girl you know what that line
won't be all right
glasses and everything the whole
aesthetic you want me to read no no
it is is [ __ ] for air condition season
is upon us
and ladies ladies treat yourself better
bro
treat yourself better this is a psa from
chelsea to you treat yourself better
okay
don't be [ __ ] no dude because it's
june in new york city you don't have air
conditioning in your shitty apartment
you share with seven other roommates
go home okay go home do not [ __ ] do
just because he got ac [ __ ] because
you love him
[ __ ] him because you got you know
something to build with him [ __ ] him
because you might think that he's a
great [ __ ] but not
for air conditioning or [ __ ] a guy who
will buy you an air conditioning pc
[ __ ] for all the single guys trying to
get some [ __ ] out here yo yeah
you don't want no girl who's [ __ ] for
air conditioning bro do you depend
single mom yeah
[Laughter]
not both of us need to get cool down
is the reason you're so hot cause you're
[ __ ] on fire [ __ ] okay
need some air conditioning from your
[ __ ]
oh man it's certain time for new york
[ __ ] gonna be
[ __ ] out here it's gonna be a while
you can feel it in the streets
yeah you can feel it in the stream there
could be some miserable [ __ ]
i don't know it's just there's an energy
manual everything's been we've been held
pent up for a year do you think this is
going to help in cells
is it going to be easier for them to
[ __ ] i don't know
the hardest thing for them is leaving
the house the hardest thing for them is
the social anxiety
so and i think that it's actually going
to make i think this year was the
easiest for them
because it was their comfort zone
everybody was home i think it's actually
going to make them even worse because
they're going to see everybody out
having the greatest time and they are
going to still be in their parents
basement
i think it's going to be in-cell season
as well it's going to be the roaring 20s
but there's also going to be some wow
[ __ ] there's going to be some [ __ ]
ups it's going to be both yeah we're
seeing it already yeah you see this in
miami
oh yeah as soon as we left there's a
mass shooting well that was weird i
didn't understand what happened
where all the details aren't out
necessarily but like basically what i
understand i can look up where it was
but basically there's like there's two
this week
there was like almost like a rap concert
i think it was like a hip hop night at
like a club
okay and then people got there okay they
got out of like uh
just a regular car like three guys and
they just started indiscriminately
shooting into like a crowd of people
waiting to get it
so that was definitely from the looks of
it is probably like a hit
they were some gang going for one person
but it just so happened there was a line
outside of people trying to get in
so what kind of lazy ass [ __ ] is that 20
people got hit go inside two people died
i mean there's no they're not the most
people i mean they sell drugs
yeah and it's like it's harder to get in
with your guns you can't get in with
your guns
oh yeah you gotta hit him before he gets
in the car come out
i mean you're trying to invent the
drive-by shooting it's not a drive-by
mass shooting that's some white people
[ __ ]
you guys are getting very are
appropriate about what i'm saying you
guys are appropriate
you didn't even drive you parked the car
and got out it's the angst everybody
wants to get back out
they couldn't even wait yeah that's a
white privilege way to kill
that is a white privilege way to kill al
and then even at that mall wait they
called it a mass shooting yeah
that's the first time they called some
black people doing [ __ ] shooting
interesting yeah
i actually don't know if they were if
they were black or not yeah but there
was
there was a shooting at the mall uh
aventura mall
on our way there that one i'm cool with
like that because that one's like
like there was you would do that it was
a dispute like no that wasn't as bad
like three three people got injured i
think but it was like they were all
having a dispute with each other about
what and then we don't know
but i'm literally on my way there and
then a guy's on an elevator with me
dressed up man sharp i'm like yeah buddy
looking sharp he's like oh appreciate it
you're getting married today
and i'm like oh it's dope congrats he
goes yeah man they shut down the venue
i'm like hey
they shut down the [ __ ] venue what's
going on and then he's like they had a
mass shooting at aventura mall yeah
we're near there
you shut down everything i'm on my way
you got married in the mall near the
mall which is it was
[ __ ] kanye literally yeah yeah yeah
come on you can't do that
lesson learned man yeah that's crazy man
wow
you really are stuttering though just
out here giving random dudes compliments
and [ __ ] like
that's some southern [ __ ] yeah we are
nice people my man's dressed sharp
you